we've heard a lot about the impact of
the corona virus on nursing homes now
we're learning the virus is hitting
patients and staff at psychiatric
facilities all across the u.s. there
have been 34 confirmed cases at Western
State Hospital in Washington it's one of
the largest psychiatric hospitals west
of the Mississippi CBS News senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge spoke to staff there Catherine
good morning what are you learning 20
good morning the state's epidemiologists
called the outbreak at Western State
both serious but also gave the hospital
credit for taking early action that may
limit infections the hospital is one of
nearly 2,000 inpatient psychiatric
facilities across the u.s. and caring
for these patients presents unique
challenges during a pandemic we are a
hospital - we are not a medical hospital
but these are patients and just because
they have a mental condition and some of
them are violent they're still human
beings the social worker Maria Claudia
works at Western State Hospital just
outside Tacoma Washington it is the
state's largest psychiatric hospital
with over 800 beds according to the
Union about 25 percent are elderly
patients are there any special measures
being taken to protect these patients on
the high-risk wards no-nothing
CBS News spoke to more than a half dozen
Western state employees who worried the
hospital isn't taking Kovan 19th
seriously they say administrators are
floating staff between wards potentially
spreading the virus and have abandoned
temperature screening workers are you
concerned that the hospital may be a
safe space for the virus to spread oh
it's it's a haven I do believe that
there's gonna be a lot of deaths staff
told us social distancing isn't a viable
option because many patients require
hands-on care we are fighting a war we
are not giving any tools to protect
anybody let alone ourselves so it's like
we're doing a suicide mission
fearing retaliation for speaking out
this hospital worker asked us to shield
her identity I think we have it worse
than a traditional hospital because our
patient's can at any given time
become violent you know we have patients
that don't understand the grasp of
coughing into your arm or sneezing into
your arm I am wearing my seahawks cloth
mask a nurse Sharon Behn third told CBS
News the hospital only recently provided
some protective equipment
after weeks of forbidding staff from
bringing their own according to internal
hospital emails nobody was allowed to
wear masks if they see you wearing masks
they will tell you to take it off close
Mariya Claudio's family bought this used
RV anticipating she will need to self
isolate in the weeks ahead like her
coworkers Claudio says she is committed
to the patients who are among society's
most isolated they rely on us for
everything they are locked in there we
have the keys we have all the power so
we have the responsibility to take care
of them
spokesperson for Western State told CBS
News that they moved quickly to protect
their high-risk population limiting
infections and now even more aggressive
actions are being taken CBS went back to
the hospital staff we interviewed who
said the changes don't come close to
addressing their ongoing concerns Tony
well if the allegations are true we do
hope those changes are made and swiftly
Katherine thank you very much